this movie was nothing like shauna the
dead
everyone who said that to me is a liar
i don't know why i watched sean of the
dead and hot fuzz beforehand
because last night in soho is not like
those films but it's funny funny and
exciting as baby driver it's funnier
than baby driver there's a lot more
action
[Laughter]
[Music]
the audio on my phone was so messed up
for the dune review that i said screw
we're putting an extension cable on the
microphone and i'm just gonna use this
road mic and talk into that today so
yeah guys we just saw last night in soho
john why don't you tell them what the
movie's about what did you know about
the movie before you watch it let's go
with that yeah okay so basically uh
thomas and mackenzie plays eloise who is
moving to londontown to pursue her dream
of becoming a fashion designer and
whilst they're feeling like an outsider
she stumbles down some rabbit holes into
the past that lead her to fantasize but
also kind of get lost in echoes of the
past involving this particular uh
up-and-coming singer yeah we won't ruin
details of the plot but they set up very
like in the first five minutes of the
movie they pretty much explained that
she has an ability to communicate with
the beyond essentially right yeah she
sees visions of her mother yeah so she
can essentially connect to spirits
ghosts okay she's in tune with the
spiritual world so i think knowing that
little fact when you watch the trailer
you're like okay this makes a lot more
sense yeah i was really looking forward
to this movie initial thoughts uh right
off the bat
i would say that the first two-thirds of
this movie i was very much in love with
i really didn't know exactly how this
was all going because i have this one
plot here about eloise she wants to get
out of the countryside and go into
fashion design school and then it
becomes a little bit like mean girls
meets the movie 8th grade it's just this
like social anxiety film and the social
anxiety only gets more ramped up because
she reveres she's very fond of the 1960s
world and the way how a lot of us are
kind of fond of of the times of old with
the the fashion the music the spirit so
when she starts connecting to on to
taylor joy's character from the past
living in those visions you get a lot of
these really cool visuals where it keeps
switching in and out of being eloise and
anya taylor joy in ways where sometimes
i get pulled out in the right way of how
the hell did they make this why did they
do that in one shot what that like
there's so much great imagery there i
love how it becomes this tale of
obsession how it's helping her out with
her fashion and that's helping her grow
as a human being and you can see that
this is becoming a positive experience
for her but if you watch the trailer
obviously it starts taking a really dark
negative path and that's where a lot of
things can be spoiled here because boy
does this movie get bonkers yes it does
you know it's funny because because
james juan did malignant yeah which had
that uh uh gelato inspiration as i call
it milk and eggs [ __ ] milk and eggs man
here you get some of that inspiration
but the edgar wright fashion
yeah absolutely and it's interesting to
see like two horror filmmakers do that
here do a modern take on cello yeah
with very different results and yet
somehow i think this movie is a little
less bonkers across the board than
malignant but they
both level of insanity yes it gets
insane it's one of my favorite movies of
the year so far i will say though i
think the last third of the movie
there's a lot about it i really really
like
and there's some stuff in there that i'm
like
a little too much that's the best way i
can tell you guys to swallow it goes no
it becomes a little twist heavy and it
seems like some plot stuff is like okay
i guess there's only there for twist but
there's so much else in there that i
really
like a lot whether that be visually
character wise like the performances all
around uh from beginning to end are very
solid i know john's more of a edgar
right fanatic than i am so what do you
think it being the man you are with
edgar wright yeah i really i really
enjoyed this movie and i mean as far as
his filmography goes obviously we're
sort of at this point now the cornetto
trilogy and scott pilgrim kind of occupy
one phase of his career and then baby
driver to me i really liked it but it
does play on a lot of things that i know
he's good at and that he flourishes in
and excels at and tonally that movie is
a bit more familiar whereas this gave me
uh what felt like him stretching his
legs into something that's much more
moody much more deliberate that does
have some of his earmarks but used in
slightly different ways i mean his neck
for visual energy and editing is really
great and yeah like you said there are
moments here where he uses those wipes
that he loves to do and those camera
tricks but in these seamless fluid and
really eerie ways where yeah you find
yourself going how on earth did is this
choreography is this like stitching what
are you doing here and yeah as a movie i
thought it was um a very personal i like
you know and i think you do too those
movies where you start with a relatable
character who goes on a descent
further and further into madness losing
themselves their grip on reality and i
think thomas and mackenzie really
carries that amazingly um and there's
also a really great supporting cast i
gotta say i have personal appreciation
for the use of shrill sound as a horror
instrument uh and not all movies do that
because it's harsh and it you know has
an effect on you but i think this movie
has an exquisite sound design especially
with how obviously edgar wright loves to
use his music cues but also the use of
echoes
and street sounds and things like that
looping and mixing audio like this
really does feel like it has a
soundscape
of a movie and so uh yeah that combined
with all the visual elements similar i'm
gonna have to kind of reflect on the
culmination and the third act see how i
feel about some of the technical aspects
of how the story wraps itself up but for
the most part i really liked what the
horror is getting at without saying too
much about it um and there are elements
of this movie that are more overtly
horror and more overtly like a haunting
ghost movie than i was expecting yeah i
mean i like i i gotta agree with you on
that because there was a portion because
you're you're settled in with this movie
so much one thing that edgar wright does
so well here is he
literally wraps you up in this film that
is two films
that eventually becomes pretty much one
film yeah because you got two stories
that you're telling you're telling the
story of a young girl first year in
college going for fashion design as a
complete outsider and then you got the
story of i'm taylor joy who meets matt
smith in the 60s and uh her pursuit of
you know big entertainment dreams it
deals with a lot of very mature themes
and so obviously you'll be cutting back
and forth between the two while louise
is experiencing the tale of the 60s but
you really got two completely different
stories here and you're watching how
they intersect and how obsession and
paranoia overtakes but it never really
felt like a horror movie but then this
movie was divided into fourths i would
say like two fourths of
not exactly 50 percent of the movie but
towards the latter half you're like okay
no this is definitely orbit this is like
direct
movie
this is a fascinating year for the
because yeah i feel like malignant is
oddly while they are very different a
good touchstone because it is that like
female lead like many gela films are you
know going to school it's like it has
gelato i need to remind you it's gelato
gelato
that movie malignant takes it and it
puts it through this filter of like a
skeezy grindhousey almost action movie
by the end of it whereas this one i felt
like takes that giallo format and then
adds the psychological horror that those
movies also have but then almost went in
a direction that reminded me of a james
one kind of ghosty fun house yes yes
because you don't want to spoil too much
but that's what i found fascinating
about this i mean if we are from doing
the comparisons here malignant still
felt like a james juan movie to me this
sure has qualities of edgar wright but i
i was less so with baby driver i'm very
much aware i'm watching an edgar wright
movie pretty much every edgar wright
movie i'm aware of it right this was the
first movie i've seen of his where i was
not aware of edgar wright for a lot of
it yeah
yeah and it's it's i think that's one of
my favorite elements is that this is
kind of what i was craving again not to
say that i didn't enjoy and really like
baby driver but this one gave me like oh
you're stretching your legs you're
expanding your palate i can still see
the edgar right but if you just showed
it to me and didn't tell me who directed
it i might not be as quick to guess it
yeah yeah it deals with some pretty
mature themes and there were times where
i was like if you go this direction in
the plot i'm gonna be kind of mad at you
movie but they managed to handle a lot
of things very well so i would say like
be prepared because there's there are
some sensitive subject matter to say the
least my one real gripe is kind of a
nitpick because i still like this
character
there's this
dude
who it like has a crush on the main
character in the movie he it like just
never
wavers like you never use best guy he's
the best in a movie filled with not good
guys man this guy just puts up with
anything this woman puts him in here
he just really must love her that much
no matter what happens no matter all the
crazy [ __ ] she goes through here he's
just always like you okay like can i do
for you when bad stuff happens to him
he's like you okay he's not concerned
for himself
in the least and i really like that
character i really like that actor but i
also was thinking throughout just like
this is just the best guy this is the
only great guy in london the longer it
went the more distracting it became yeah
yeah i'll give you that he doesn't
because of how
gray a lot of the characters get drawn
and how much trauma is on display and
how much sort of cultural you know
you're dealing with the swing in 60s and
part of this movie takes that thing a
lot of people say now which is man i
wish i lived during that time and then
it turns it inside out
i don't think you want to live in that
time because there's a lot of nasty
behavior going on behind the curtains of
all the glamorous nightlife that you
idolize and then when it comes to like
social commentary it shows you that like
hey those times
everything that we deal with today that
we are more vocal about it's been
existent for for
pretty much ever yes and it was even
existed in the times that we thought
were like just perfect
yeah i would say like i'm
like 4.5 out of 5 for some [ __ ] all
right i'm with you i'm with you g we're
back in sync all right we're back
halloween and
we're back here we're back back to
sherry opinions thank you guys for being
here and uh we'll catch you guys soon